>> Colleen Shogan: Good morning.
My name is Colleen Shogan.
And I'm the Deputy Director
of our outreach unit here
at the Library of Congress.
And it's my privilege
to welcome you
to the 18th annual
National Book Festival.
As you may know, the Library
of Congress is the largest
library in the world.
We have millions of books.
Manuscripts.
Photographs.
Newspapers.
Maps. Comics.
And other items in
our collection.
We're thrilled that
you're here today with us.
We also invite you to come
visit us on Capitol Hill.
Or online at loc.gov.
Today we welcome author James
Swanson to the teen stage.
He is the award-winning author
of the best-selling page turner
"Manhunt, the 12-Day Chase
For Lincoln's Killer."
He also wrote a YA
adaptation for "Manhunt" along
with a young adult
nonfiction book
on the Kennedy assassination.
His most recent book, the book
we're going to hear about today,
is "Chasing King's Killer."
Which is about the murder
of Martin Luther King,
Jr. I just finished James's
book a few weeks ago.
It's a terrifically
detailed account
of the unfortunate
circumstances leading
to the King assassination.
There's a lot of true
crime detail in the book.
Including sketches.
Diagrams. Photographs.
And maps. Which help the
reader understand what happened
on that fateful day in 1968.
We learn a great deal about
Martin Luther King, Jr. His roll
as a leader of the
civil rights movement.
"Chasing King's Killer" also
provides fascinating details
about how the assassin, James
Earl Ray, used disguises
and other tricks to
allude the police
and the FBI after the murder.
This is a real page turner.
I started reading the book
one night before going to bed,
and I finished it next day.
And that's the sign of
a very, very good book.
Please join me in welcoming
to the teen stage one
of the best historical
crime writers
in the United States
today, James Swanson.
[ Applause ]
>> James L. Swanson:
Thank you, Colleen.
It's great to be back at
the National Book Festival.
This is my fifth time here.
And I love coming here to meet
all of you and meet the readers.
So why did I write this book?
This is the final
book in my trilogy
on American assassinations.
About Abraham Lincoln.
John F. Kennedy.
And Martin Luther King.
And I focused on these
three great American heroes.
It's not that I'm obsessed
with death and violence.
But rather key moments of
change in American history.
When something happens, and
everything changes overnight.
And nothing is ever
the same again.
This book is also set in
the turbulent 1960s America.
For those who remember
or those who don't,
those were the years
of the Vietnam War.
The race to the moon.
Civil unrest.
Riots in the streets.
And assassinations.
Not just of Dr. King.
But of Malcolm X.
President Kennedy.
Robert Kennedy.
It was a tumultuous,
confusing time.
The book covers Martin
Luther King's entire life,
from childhood to his adulthood.
But it especially
focuses on his last years.
So this is not just
a book about death.
It's about a great life
and a heroic life too.
For me this is probably
the most personal
of these three books
of this trilogy.
I remember the night that
Martin Luther King was killed.
In the riots that followed, my
father drove me through parts
of our home town Chicago,
that had burned to the ground.
Until recently, parts of
our city had never recovered
in the last 50 years since
the death of Dr. King.
I remember going to
our local post office
and seeing reward posters
for the assassin pinned
to the bulletin board.
Posters which I now
have in my collection
and which I share
with you in the book.
So this book, probably
more than the other two,
is my way of bringing
the past that I lived
through as a boy to
a new generation.
And the reason I write books
for children and for teens is
that I don't think you
have to be spectators
or observers of history.
You can actually be part of it.
Young people were a
very important part
of the civil rights movement.
Just as they're involved
in it today.
So where does the book begin?
It begins in 1958, ten years
before King's assassination.
And it begins with a stabbing.
A little known episode
in King's life.
King was just becoming
famous for his leadership
of the 1955 Montgomery
bus boycott.
And he was in New York City
to promote his first book,
"Strive Toward Freedom."
And it was going so well.
He was at a department
store in Harlem.
He was sitting at a desk,
and he was signing books.
And then a well-dressed
middle-aged black woman
approached him.
She fit right in with the crowd.
Nothing looked bad.
And she said, are you
Martin Luther King?
And he looked up and
said, well, yes, I am.
And with that she drew a letter
opener, but it was razor sharp
like a miniature samurai sword.
She pulled it out of her bag.
She raised it up
high in the air.
And plunged it into his chest.
And she stabbed him so hard
that the handle broke off.
And the blade stayed
embedded in his chest.
It looked like it was
right where his heart was.
Immediately there
was panic and chaos.
Someone reached for the
blade to pull it out.
But then someone
shouted, don't do that.
You'll kill him if
you pull it out.
It was true.
As doctors would find out
later, the blade was so close
to King's aorta that any
movement, even coughing
or a sneeze, could have
led to his instant death.
But he didn't die.
King woke up hours later
in a Harlem hospital.
He had survived.
He would live.
So why do I begin the book here,
ten years before the
main story of the book?
I begin here because
King's life could have been
over before it ever
really began.
If he had been killed
in that stabbing,
we might not even remember the
name of Martin Luther King.
The woman's name
was Izola Curry.
And she was deemed later
to be mentally ill.
She was charged with attempted
murder, but she spent the rest
of her life in mental
institutions.
And she's one of the last
survivors of this whole tale.
She died just three years
ago in her late 90s in 2015.
But by then she'd really
forgotten what she had done
and how she almost
changed history forever.
Upon Martin Luther King's
release from the hospital,
he asked that there be
no vengeance against her
and that she not be punished.
But that she get
support and understanding
for the treatment she needed.
But if she had succeeded, how
would our world be different?
We might ask, what would the
world, what would America be
like without that crucial decade
of Martin Luther
King's leadership?
What great words would
have gone unspoken?
What great deeds would
have gone undone?
Martin Luther King had just
narrowly escaped death.
And from that moment on,
he thought he was
living on borrowed time.
So what about King's
life in these ten years,
in this short decade
from 1958 to '68?
It was a year filled, a
decade filled with excitement.
Turmoil. Great success.
Great setbacks.
In 1963, Martin Luther King led
the famous march on Washington
that climaxed at the
Lincoln Memorial.
Where he spoke to a
crowd of 250,000 people.
And said, I have a dream.
In 1964, he received
the Nobel Peace Prize.
And worked hard for
civil rights legislation
that would pass soon.
The Civil Rights Act.
The Voting Rights Act.
In 1965, he led the
famous march from Selma
to Montgomery, Alabama.
Those were years of
challenge and change
for Dr. King and all Americans.
In 1967, he took a major
stand against the Vietnam War.
But by the late 1960s,
King's leadership
of the civil rights movement
was increasingly challenged
by younger more radical leaders.
King faced a number of
failures and setbacks,
and these discouraged him.
King experienced
great self-doubt.
And he began to wonder, was
he the right man to continue
to lead this movement?
Was he the right
man for the job?
Then on April 3, 1968,
King was in Memphis,
Tennessee to support the
city sanitation workers
who were striking for
better working conditions.
King was exhausted
from extensive travel.
He was faced with a mounting
burden of inner doubt
about his own abilities
as a leader.
He was sick with a sore
throat and a fever.
And that night there
was a massive storm
with pouring rain and thunder.
And the last thing he
wanted to do was go outside
and go and give a speech.
But he did.
At 8:30 p.m., King appeared
at the Mason Temple and spoke
to an overflowing
crowd of 3,000 people.
And in this speech, arguably
the best of his life,
he summarized his life
and highlighted something
that had happened to
him ten years before.
He told the audience
how he'd been stabbed
by Izola Curry a decade before.
He revealed that, as he
recovered from that attack,
he had received a letter
from a young white girl.
A ninth grade student
who had read
about what had happened to him.
And in her letter,
King said she wrote.
I read that, if you'd
sneezed, you would have died.
I'm simply writing
you to say that I'm
so happy you didn't sneeze.
King repeated her
words, and he said,
I'm so glad I didn't sneeze.
He said, if I had sneezed,
I couldn't have been
there at Selma.
I couldn't have been in
the march on Washington.
I couldn't be here tonight.
He appreciated how he lived in
the last decade and the years
of progress, though not
perfect, that had been made.
King ended the speech by saying
what I think are his finest
public remarks.
Even greater than the
march on Washington.
So he said, like anybody, I
would like to live a long life.
Longevity has its place, but I'm
not concerned about that now.
I just want to do God's will.
And he's allowed me to go
up to the mountain,
and I've looked over.
And I have seen the
promised land.
I may not get there with you.
But I want you to
know tonight that we
as a people will get
to the promised land.
And I'm so happy tonight.
I'm not worried about anything.
I'm not fearing any man.
Mine eyes have seen the glory
of the coming of the Lord.
Then he collapsed into the arms
of his best friend,
Ralph Abernathy.
Later Abernathy said, I've
never seen him better.
But he should have
feared one man.
A few miles away a man waited
at a seedy hotel with a rifle.
The next day Martin Luther King
would be dead, assassinated
by perhaps the most
unlikely killer.
An escaped convict and petty
criminal named James Earl Ray.
So who was this Ray?
He had grown up diet
poor in Missouri
in a family of career criminals.
Strangely, he was just the
kind of underprivileged,
uneducated child that Martin
Luther King would have wanted
to help.
By Ray's teenage years,
he was living the life
of a failed criminal.
He was in and out of jail
until in 1959, he was sentenced
to a 20-year term for robbery.
And if he had served
that entire sentence,
we never would have
heard of James Earl Ray.
Except in 1967, he escaped.
So why did he want to
kill Martin Luther King?
James Earl Ray did not escape
from prison with a plan
to assassinate Dr. King.
No, he escaped to reinvent
himself and forge a new life.
He traveled to Canada.
Mexico. And California.
He took professional
bartending lessons.
Dance classes.
And locksmithing courses.
The one thing he did not
do is stalk Dr. King.
For exactly one year from
March 1967 to March 1968,
Ray enjoyed his new life.
There's no evidence he even
thought about Dr. King.
That all changed when
King flew to Los Angeles
and gave a speech near
Disneyland on March 16th, 1968.
The next day on March
17th, King flew home.
But on that same day,
James Earl Ray packed
up all his belongings, got
in his Mustang sports car.
And drove all the way across
the country from California,
ultimately to Memphis,
Tennessee.
And on the way he
bought a rifle.
Something in Ray had changed.
Like a caged homing pigeon
or hibernating animal,
Ray responded to an inner
call that only he could hear.
It would direct his movements
for the next three weeks.
It was though a silent
alarm had rung inside him,
summoning him South.
By April 3rd, 1968, Ray was in
Memphis, where Dr. King was.
That night King spoke
at the Mason Temple
and gave that great speech.
The next morning Ray found a
rooming house with a direct view
of the Lorraine Hotel,
where King was staying.
But Ray's room didn't have a
clear view of the Lorraine.
The windows were on
in the wrong place.
It would have been
impossible to attack Dr. King.
So Ray went to a common
bathroom down the hall.
He punched out the
window screen.
But the window itself was stuck.
There were just a few inches at
the bottom that were still open.
Just enough space to poke
out the barrel of a rifle.
But even then, the view
wasn't completely clear.
So Ray had to stand
in the bathtub
to get an unobstructed
view of King's room.
When Dr. King finally
emerged from his hotel room
around six o'clock for dinner,
James Earl Ray was
watching and waiting.
As King stood on the balcony
outside his room and looked
down at his friends
in the parking lot.
And spoke to them
about going to dinner.
James Earl Ray got
him in the sights
of his telescope
and fired one shot.
The bullet hit Dr. King
in the right cheek.
Entered his neck.
Severed arteries.
Crashed through his spine.
People watching yelled,
Dr. King has been shot.
He was immediately
rushed to the hospital.
But an EKG show he
had no heart function.
Doctors tried valiantly
to resuscitate him
for almost an hour.
But at 7:05 p.m., only one
hour after he was shot,
he was pronounced dead.
Martin Luther King, Jr.,
the great civil rights
leader was gone.
So what about his assassin?
Unbelievably, after the
murder James Earl Ray escaped
and disappeared.
Speeding away in his Mustang,
he fled the murder scene
without a moment to spare.
One minute after he
escaped, the police showed
up at the door where he escaped.
And they would have
captured him on the spot,
but he escaped just
in the nick of time.
His escape launched
the biggest manhunt
in the history of the FBI.
Three thousand agents, half
the entire FBI were put
on the chase to find the killer.
To identify who he was.
No one knew the man named James
Earl Ray had killed Dr. King.
They only knew that
an unknown man.
It took weeks.
Ray eventually made
his way to Canada.
Then to England and Portugal.
And finally back to England
when he couldn't arrange passage
to Africa, where he hoped to
become a paid mercenary in one
of the white-ruled governments.
In fact, it was only
a slip of fate
that his passport was double
checked at Heathrow Airport
in London on June 8th, 1968,
leading to his eventual arrest.
It took 106 days from
King's assassination
to raise extradition from
England to the United States.
And, in fact, it
was only 15 months
since Ray had escaped
from prison.
One of history's most
shocking possibilities is that,
if James Earl Ray had
escaped to Africa,
he probably would have
disappeared for good.
And the murder of Dr. King would
have escaped justice forever.
But he was caught.
Ray spent the rest of
his life in prison.
He survived Martin Luther King
by 30 years, dying in 1998.
So what should we take
away from this story?
For those of us who remember
it, it's hard to believe
that it's been 50
years, 1968 to 2018,
that doctor King was killed.
If he was alive today, and
that's not inconceivable,
he would be 89 years old.
He was only 39 when he died.
Such a young man.
But he might still be
alive, leading the charge
for equal rights
and fair treatment.
How we could have
benefited from five decades
of his continued leadership.
Imagine if he was
here all that time.
What would Dr. King
say to us today?
I think he might ask us to turn
to something he said in 1965
when he stood on the steps of
the state capital in Montgomery,
Alabama, after the successful
march from Selma to Montgomery.
Standing there he
asked a question
that still reverberates today.
Dr. King said, how
long will it take?
He said, how long will prejudice
blind the visions of men?
Darken their understanding
and drive bright-eyed wisdom
from her sacred throne?
How long will justice be
crucified and truth bear it?
And you know what he said?
Dr. King said, how long?
Not long. Because the arc
the moral universe is long,
but it bends towards justice.
And he repeated that
phrase over and over again.
How long will it take?
And then he gave the answer.
Certainly much progress
has been made,
that doctor King
would say that today.
But he would also say even
more needs to be done.
So I ask you today, and I
think that Dr. King would say
to us now, how long
will it take?
And with that I thank you.
And would love to
take questions.
So please ask.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, mister, no.
Okay, not yet.
>> James L. Swanson: Okay.
>> Oh, okay.
Sorry.
>> James L. Swanson: Yeah.
>> I was just wondering, did
you ever get any like blow back
from like publishers or
even parents for writing
about assassinations for young
adult and middle grade readers?
I really enjoyed your
books by the way.
>> James L. Swanson:
Strangely, not really.
I talked to a lot of young
readers, including my two boys,
when I wrote my first
assassination book on Lincoln.
They were seven and nine.
And one boy said,
readers want blood.
And the other boy
said, and knives.
Also, here's why I don't
get blow back from parents.
And I've discussed this with
parents, with kids and adults.
I also asked my friend
Congressman John Lewis
about this, who wrote a
wonderful forward to the book.
And I said, you know,
I don't want to look
like I'm exploiting
the death of Dr. King.
He said, no, tell the
story like it was.
Tell it like it happened.
It's a real story.
It's not fiction.
Martin Luther King was killed in
a horrible way by a racist man.
A wife lost her husband.
Children lost their father.
So part of the violence
in my books is real.
I don't want kids to think
it's fun or it's not real.
Or that violence doesn't
have consequences.
I also set it in the
context of history
and what really happened.
And so that's why young people
and parents and teachers
and librarians have told me they
appreciate the vivid realism
of my books.
But they don't find it salacious
or exploitive for
its own purpose.
So people have been
very accepting
of the way I write the books.
>> Thank you.
>> James L. Swanson: Yes.
>> Hi, I just wanted
to thank you quickly
for writing the books.
I remember in seventh grade
we were assigned to read it.
And it was really a
breakthrough for me
because it's what got me really
interested in American history.
I was just wondering about
"Chasing Lincoln's Killer."
Was it difficult to
sort of adapt "Manhunt"
into something for young adults.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> It was.
It was. In my ignorance
I thought,
oh, this will be so easy.
I'll just edit down
the adult book
into a little young adult book.
"Manhunt" was about
140,000 words long.
And "Chasing Lincoln's
Killer," I think was
about 30, 32,000 words long.
I was quickly disabused
of how easy it would be.
And I felt like I had to
really write a new book.
I just couldn't edit it down.
I really needed to
write it for teens.
So I wrote it really for
my boys or the boy I was.
I think one reason I enjoy
writing books for teens is,
in many ways I'm still
the kid I always was.
That has advantages
and disadvantages.
But I mentioned how I would
want to read the story.
And the main difference
between writing for teens
and adults is you
cannot dumb it down.
They always know.
I knew when I was a kid, and
you kids in the audience know it
when adults are speaking
down to you.
Or when they're concealing
something from you.
The main thing is you
have to take out some
of the tertiary characters.
You have to take out maybe
some of the irony or some
of the incongruities
or the foreshadowing.
So I really had to
rewrite the book entirely
for a younger audience.
It's not easy to do.
And I've done other young adult
books based on adult books.
And I learned my
lesson the first time.
That you really have
to write a new book
that speaks to a teen audience.
>> Thank you.
>> James L. Swanson: Yes.
>> Hi, I was going to ask you
how do you get into the point
of view of the assassin
who's like so evil?
>> James L. Swanson: How
do I get into the point
of view of the assassin?
Well, in the case of Lincoln
and certainly the case
of James Earl Ray, all my books.
The heroes are these great
heroes of American life.
Abraham Lincoln.
John Kennedy.
And Martin Luther King.
And by the end of the book, I
want it to be absolutely clear
that those people and what
they stood for are the heroes
and guiding principles
of the book.
But in the case of
John Wilkes Booth,
I want you to know what it's
like to be in the saddle,
galloping away on an escape.
To know what it's like to
be a wounded, hunted man.
think, you think you're going
to be a great hero to the South.
But then read the newspapers
that say you're a devil.
You've done evil.
And in the case of James
Earl Ray, he was a cipher.
He was a racist.
He killed one of the greatest
men in American history.
But I want you the reader
to decide how evil they are.
The bad they've done.
How great King and
Kennedy and Lincoln are.
And so I don't say in the book
Booth is evil or Booth is bad.
I want you the reader to come
to your own conclusion
that that is true.
So I want to give you the facts.
Put you in the position
of Lincoln.
To put you in Booth's position.
And Ray's position.
And I'm confident that young
readers will have the judgment
and discernment to know who
the heroes of the books are
and who the bad men are.
I think it would be a mistake
to start a book by saying,
you know, the evil John
Wilkes Booth, you know,
on page one or page two.
I want you to see him and know
him and judge him yourself.
So that's kind of
the technique I use.
>> Thank you.
>> James L. Swanson: Yes.
>> I was wondering,
are you going
to write any more young adult
books about American history?
>> James L. Swanson: I am.
I'm working on a book with
Henry Lewis Gates from Harvard.
And we're writing a book
on what I think is one
of the greatest untold
African-American history
stories ever.
And we're doing an
adult book of that.
And we're also doing
a young adult book
for my publisher Scholastic.
And I'm working on a few
other young adult books also.
But that's probably
going to be the next one.
I really enjoy doing them.
Because I love going
to the schools.
I love getting the letters
from the young readers.
So I get a lot of personal
satisfaction from doing that.
So I want to keep
writing young adult books.
>> Thank you.
I love your books.
>> James L. Swanson:
Oh, thank you.
Yes.
>> Good morning.
I think it's possible with
a lot of study to see some
of the motivations
of John Wilkes Booth
and Lee Harvey Oswald.
Sort of understand why
they did these things.
James Earl Ray, I'm curious of
your opinion about motivation.
Because racism doesn't seem
to have been what drove him
around through his
criminal career.
I've heard rumors, I'm not sure
how the historians have treated
them, about their being
a pot money people used
to gossip about in the South.
That if you killed King,
there'd be some people
to pay you off or something.
What do you think
drove James Earl Ray?
>> James L. Swanson:
Well, James Earl Ray is
in many ways a mystery
or a cipher.
He himself loved the fact that
people couldn't remember him.
They couldn't remember
that they had met him.
He had that every-man look.
We know this.
James Earl Ray was
a lifelong racist.
But that was common at
that time, in that place.
Millions of his fellow Americans
shared his racial views.
He was never part of the Klan.
He never participated
in racial violence.
He never seemed to obsess
with Martin Luther King.
And so, when he escaped from
prison, we know he didn't escape
for the purpose of
hunting Dr. King.
And he always wanted
live in the shadows.
We don't know what went on
in his mind when King came
to California, and then Ray
drove across the country
and murdered him
three weeks later.
I don't believe it
was a conspiracy.
There's no evidence that it was.
He didn't seem to have
personal hatred for Dr. King.
There were rumors that
a wealthy white man
in the South had put a
$50,000 bounty on King's head.
But if that's true, how
could Ray have ever collected
that reward?
Would he have just showed
up at his door and said,
hello, I'm the wanted man.
Where's my money?
After studying Ray
for a long time,
I think Ray in the end
wanted to be something
or do something worthwhile.
He thought he'd be a hero to
racists if he killed King.
He thought he'd be remembered.
So I think Martin Luther
King was the vehicle
through which James Earl
Ray could achieve a place
in history.
The frustrating thing is,
although Ray lived for 30 years
and he plead guilty initially,
he tried to retract that plea.
For 30 years he claimed
he didn't do it.
There are dozens and
dozens of pieces of evidence
that proved it was him.
He claimed he wasn't
even the triggerman,
not just conspirators sent him.
He claimed he didn't
fire the rifle.
Evidence proves that he did.
So the great frustration
is, although he lived
for three decades, Ray
never told us why he did it.
He never would admit
that he did do it.
So it's one of the
great mysteries.
But I think of all the evidence
indicates that Ray did it
for personal significance
or achievement.
To see that somehow he had
made a mark in the world.
That's my best guess.
Yes.
>> Two part question.
First part, with your
books on King and Kennedy,
did you get any feedback
from the families?
Because you, obviously, with
Lincoln that was a long,
long time ago, but
these are still families
that are alive and in existence.
And the King family,
particularly,
has watched over
their father's legacy.
So any feedback from them?
>> James L. Swanson:
No, I did not.
The Kennedy family prefers not
to discuss the assassination.
And, in fact, they don't like
to mark November 22nd, 1963.
They prefer to celebrate
John Kennedy's birthday.
And so they're not really
interested in the assassination.
I have talked to a number
of John Kennedy's friends.
And I know Clint Hill, the
heroic secret service agent
who leaped on the car to
shield Jackie Kennedy.
And these people have been
very complimentary of the book
and my take on John Kennedy.
I have heard talk to Lyndon
Johnson's family about my books.
And I think LBJ is
a great unsung hero
of civil rights in America.
And I'm a big fan of
the Lyndon Johnson.
And they've appreciated
my take on LBJ.
I've not heard from
the King family.
The King family, in large part,
belive there's was a massive
U.S. government conspiracy
to murder their father.
And there's a shocking
photograph of one
of Dr. King's sons visiting
James Earl Ray in prison.
Reaching out his hand to
shake the hand of the man who,
in fact, without a doubt
murdered his father.
But I've not heard
from them directly.
It's unfortunate that they've
had this contact with the man
who killed their father.
But I've not heard from them.
>> And then the second part,
and you just alluded to that.
Did the King family, with their
background, do they forgive?
>> James L. Swanson: Well,
one of Kings son's said,
we believe you did
not kill our father.
And so there was not
really forgiveness
because he said, we
don't believe it.
That I do not believe is true.
James Earl Ray was the assassin
of Dr. Martin Luther King.
I think that's proven
without any doubt whatsoever.
The conspiracy theories
are interesting.
They're a world unto themselves.
And I do address the conspiracy
theories in the books.
We want to believe them.
Because we believe that,
if someone like Martin Luther
King can be struck down,
John F Kennedy.
What hope do we have for order
and planning in our lives
if great men of history can
be struck down randomly?
We want to believe there's
a larger pattern behind our
misfortunes or terrible
things in the world.
It's so natural, the
human impulse to want
to believe these
conspiracy theories.
But they're most often not true.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> James L. Swanson: Yes.
>> Good morning.
I have a process question.
So as a nonfiction writer,
how do you take primary
and secondary source,
historical sources
and weave those into your books?
>> James L. Swanson: The
thing I'm most interested
in is the objects and documents
and artifact themselves.
In this book I include a lot
of original documents
and artifacts.
Like mourning buttons
that people would put
on their clothes to
remember Dr. King.
Posters. Music of the time.
Recordings.
Dr. King's speeches.
And I do recommend and my
extensive notes refer you
to Dr. King's speeches.
You should listen to him
when you read this book.
It's, you're losing a
lot if you don't listen
to his words as you
read the book.
I try to find rarely
seen photographs.
Very detailed maps.
Immersing myself in the sources.
Going to the places
where history happened.
Holding in my hands the objects.
Holding in my hands the reward
posters in my collection.
And then showing
them to the reader.
Those are the most
important sources to me.
The original magazines.
The newspapers.
The sound recordings.
The photographs.
The artifacts.
I really want to immerse myself
back in that world and feel
like I'm living back
in that time.
That's probably the
key method that I use.
>> Thank you.
>> Excuse, can I
ask my question?
>> James L. Swanson: Yes.
>> Like, why did the King
children, why did Dexter,
why was he allowed to go to the
prison to talk to his killer
in 1997 the year before he died?
Why did they allow
him to do that?
>> James L. Swanson: Well,
James Earl Ray was allowed
to receive visitors in prison.
And Dexter King requested
to visit James Earl Ray
for the purpose of telling Ray
that he didn't believe
he killed his father.
So no one could really
prevented that.
Ray was allowed to
receive visitors.
Dexter King wanted to see him.
I think it's so unfortunate.
The photo of Martin Luther
King's son shaking hands
with the man who killed
his father is heartbreaking
for me to see.
>> Why is it heartbreaking
for you to see
that he would do that?
>> James L. Swanson: Because
Ray did murder his father.
The King family is wrong
about that, sad to say.
James Earl Ray was the man
who killed Martin Luther King.
And it was just sad to see one
of King's sons shake the hand
of the man who actually
killed his father.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> I have another.
Like, why didn't
Kennedy's family want
to mark the anniversary
of his death?
Why didn't they?
>> James L. Swanson: They want
the living JFK to be remembered.
The murder of President Kennedy
was a searing experience.
It was captured on film.
It's one of the most horrific
films in American history.
It seared Jackie
Kennedy, who witnessed it.
And she preferred to never
speak publicly about the murder
of her husband again after 1963.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> And do you think it had
to do with Russia or Cuba,
why Kennedy was murdered?
Do you think it [inaudible] with
Oswald marrying the Russian?
>> James L. Swanson: No.
There's not time
to get to that now.
But if you look at my adult
and my young adult JFK book,
Lee Harvey Oswald was the man
who murdered President Kennedy.
>> Did it have to do with his,
because he visited two
communists who hated the U.S.?
And did they give him influence
and convince him
to get [inaudible].
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> James L. Swanson:
Absolutely not.
>> Why don't you think it had
to do with Russia or Cuba?
>> James L. Swanson: Well,
all I can say is the
evidence suggests it.
But there's one more question,
and we're running out of time.
So can I take your question.
>> Yes, please.
And thank you so much.
I think that authors
really are seekers of truth.
But I always wonder.
Is there a moment of doubt
when you find your words
to express what you saw
and maybe the words
what you research.
And maybe the words are not
deep enough or strong enough?
How do you get past,
if it happens to you?
How do you get past that moment
of doubt in the process and art
of expressing the
truth you found?
>> James L. Swanson:
Well, in other words,
express it more clearly?
>> Yeah.
>> James L. Swanson: Or fully?
>> Right.
>> James L. Swanson: Okay.
Well, I think we all
suffer from that problem.
And I agree with
what Steven King said
in his wonderful
book on writing.
King said, even the best of us,
and I don't say I'm
the best of us.
King himself says he's
not the best among us.
King says, all writers
experience the frustration
of knowing that the words
that appear on the page,
no matter how many drafts we do.
How many times we rewrite it.
We often feel that the words we
write don't fully express the
emotions we feel.
And I think it's just
endemic to be a writer
where we always think
we can do it better.
Be more precise or express the
feelings of us or others better.
It's one of the frustrating
things about writing books.
You always ask yourself,
could I have done that better?
>> Well, thanks for the
courage to be an author.
>> James L. Swanson: Yeah.
>> I read in your "Chasing
Lincoln's Killer" that,
when you were young, that
your grandmother gave you an
engraving of the
Derringer pistol.
How did you get into
the assassinations
of great American heroes?
>> James L. Swanson: Well,
with Lincoln, there was,
I was born on Lincoln's
birthday.
And I studied Lincoln
since I was a boy.
I barely remember the
Kennedy assassination.
And I wanted to write
about things
that happened in my lifetime.
I loved writing about Lincoln,
but we don't know
anyone who knew Lincoln.
We can't talk to
someone who knew Lincoln.
I could talk to people who
were friends of John Kennedy.
I could meet people who were
friends of Martin Luther King.
And I wanted to write
about things
that happened in my lifetime.
Where I could still talk to the
people who lived through it.
And I think we've run out
of time; is that right?
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]